welcome I'm Sharon Marcus this is a very
large microphone I'm the Dean of
humanities here at Columbia University
and I would like to begin by thanking
ambassador Jean Kennedy Smith for
establishing this award and her brothers
honor i'm on i'm honored to welcome you
to columbia university where we are
proud to host tonight's award ceremony
for the kennedy prize for drama inspired
by american history theater and history
an interesting pair theater is ephemeral
history deals with what lasts where
theater embraces artifice history aims
for truth but theater and history alike
strive to bring written text to life
both seek to understand what drives us
forward and what holds us back what
defines our present moment and what
connects us to the past as for Columbia
University in theater well as the saying
goes we have a history we are of course
columbia university in the city of new
york which has long been the nation's
theatre capitole before ellis island
became an immigrant depot in the 1850s
it housed a theater a nineteenth-century
observer wrote I question if there be a
city in the world of the same size and
population which can exhibit a
theatrical prosperity equal to New York
Columbia University's English department
was co-founded by Brander Matthews a
prominent drama critic who then
president whom then President cephalo
appointed as the first professor of
dramatic literature in the United States
and whose collection of theater
memorabilia continues to grace our
magnificent Rare Book and Manuscript
collection Columbia College numbers
among our alumni such theatrical
luminaries as Oscar Hammerstein the
second Richard Rodgers lorenz hart john
kander fred ebb terrence mcnally Janine
sasori and of course Tony Kushner we
continue to nurture the production and
study of theater through our school of
the arts theater
em and through our distinguished PhD in
theatre it's Dean of humanities I work
with faculty whose mission is to
preserve expand and enrich our shared
cultural history that history and our
nation's theatrical history include our
country's propensity for racial
classification and discrimination for
racial expression as well as racist
oppression so I'd like to offer you a
few glimpses of my encounters with that
theatrical past that I've made over the
years over a decade of doing research on
19th century theater many scholars
including some here at Columbia have
documented the importance of performance
both voluntary and coerced for African
Americans but it's also important to
remember that for centuries with rare
exceptions African and Asian Americans
were not allowed to represent themselves
on stage in the United States white
actors in blackface played the main
characters in Uncle Tom's Cabin well
into the 20th century although in 1880
some productions began to advertise so
called colored actors appearing as
extras in the plantation scenes so
common wear blackface and yellow face
white performers playing people of color
in Broadway plays that as recently as
1917 a playbill vaunted as an utter
novelty colored actors in colored plays
our theaters including those in northern
cities were segregated playbills for
productions in abolitionist Boston in
1858 listed a separate set of ticket
prices for colored people who were
allowed only in second-tier boxes an
1873 letter to the editor of the New
York Herald by a theater goer who signed
himself quote black but decent painfully
and painstakingly recounted having
visiting the booth theatre to see a
production of Shakespeare's Richard the
third he was shunted from one section of
the theater to another reserved for
black people our greatest playwrights
take this painful history and wrestle
with its angels and demons like the best
scholars they engage in an act of
alchemy that conjures up the past and
brings it flashing in
the present that act of alchemy reminds
us of the truth of William Faulkner's
pithy insight that the past is never
dead it's not even past and it reminds
us of the mission that Columbia
University shares with theatre and we
hope with great leaders such as Edward
Kennedy a mission to on earth and
understand the past that unites and
divides us so that instead of repeating
history we can represent it in ways that
help us work together to imagine and
make a better future thank you so that
was magnificent Dean Marcus thank you
and welcome to the third annual Edward M
Kennedy Prize ceremony where we're
really really happy to have you here the
prize recognizes that theater in the
hands of a serious artist is a means of
examining whether the fighing and
exploring our history and bringing to
the collective task of remembering the
past in addition to the complexity and
depth of historical scholarship the
flashes of collective insight and
illumination the special that's the
special contribution of our odd and
evanescent and elusive and ambiguous and
essential form this is a really
particularly meaningful day for me
because we're now in our third year
we've worked very hard to get to this
point at three years old I don't feel
like we're absolutely firmly established
on the planet but we're on our way fifth
year I'll start to feel really the
ground is solid under our feet but it's
been a lot of very hard work I want to
thank people for most for today and for
all the work leading up today I want to
thank my fellow board member mandy
Michelle Hackett who is just you know
God send James Neal who is the chief
librarian at Columbia who Shepherd us
into existence is has resigned as chief
librarian serving as interim librarian
is Damon Jagger's who's been an
extraordinary help and Minnie and
Morales who sort of transitions us from
James into the future has been
absolutely indispensable also matt
hempel and everybody at columbia
university i want to thank the entire
university community for being such an
incredibly welcoming and supportive
environment for the prize i also want to
thank all of our twenty nominators i
can't say who they are because it's a
top secret so that people don't call
them up and beg them to nominate their
place but some of them have served since
the beginning we rotate a few new ones
in every year Mandy and I do the work
mostly of a finding these people and
they've done an astonishing job every
year and I think this year is obviously
no exception and then just two more
things I just want to say on a personal
note because I have to say this i think
that the four plays that that have
received the kennedy prize have all been
extraordinary works this year I I feel
like I have to say the price is going to
a writer who I consider to be not only
one of the greatest playwrights this
country is produced but one of the
greatest living writers and and somebody
in who
and of whom I'm genuinely at all and I
it makes it feel like it's all
worthwhile that this year's recipient is
a suzan-lori parks so my last my last
thank you of course and it'll be this
every year until I stop doing this is of
course ambassador Jean Kennedy Smith who
created this prize who got me into this
and it's taken years off of my life but
but but I'm very glad for those years
we've now as I said made for playwrights
a little more solvent which is a really
good thing and a little happier
playwrights should never be too happy
because we wouldn't be able to do good
work if we were but Oh for at least for
tonight suzan-lori will be happy and
we're all have for her and I think that
what Jean did in in honoring her brother
for two reasons is an extraordinary
thing one is that she the prize and
we're all really very moved and proud of
this honors one of the great legislators
in American history one of our great
senators we've had recent reminders in
the news of how not great senators can
be so you know it's it's wonderful to
have the memory of a genuinely great
statesman like Ted Kennedy to to sort of
comfort ourselves with when we read
about other people who I won't mention
um and and it's it's an extraordinary
thing the gene has done for American
playwriting I think in in highlighting
the connection between playwriting and
history that Dean Marcus just talking
about so beautifully in and simply in
providing support for playwrights it's
extremely difficult for playwrights to
make a living as playwrights these days
and there's nothing more important than
supporting newcomers to the field and
so masters of the craft like suzan-lori
it's it's a it's an extraordinarily
generous and beautiful thing and Jean
and the entire Kennedy family deserve
our eternal gratitude so thank you so
I love the program I'm just gonna
explain one thing now I'm going to sit
down Ted Kennedy jr. and Patrick Kennedy
you're going to get up and they're going
to talk to you for a little bit then
there's a film that we put together
about the life of Edward M Kennedy then
it's on your program but each year for
the past three years as you're going to
learn from the film and maybe from what
his sons are about to tell you senator
Kennedy I hope it's okay today this is
sort of like a musical theatre Queen and
he really loved musicals so every year
I'm sure he would my I didn't know him
but I'm sure he wouldn't mind resident
gene may have something to say to me
afterwards business so every year we've
had a different performer from the
musical theatre come in and perform and
this year the great Tony award-winning
Chuck Cooper is going to sing Kristen
he's going to be accompanied by after
the film by the extraordinary composer
Ginny inches already on some of my dear
friend so thank you for coming thank you
again tony kushner let's give Tony
another round of applause i'm ted
kennedy jr. and i just simply want to
say thank you for all four for all of
you to come here tonight honor my father
i would like to thank the nominators i
want to thank the board i want to thank
Mandy and Tony for your steadfast
support your vision for this award of
course we wouldn't be here without you
gene and no one could have had a better
sister than you and we are my father was
so lucky to have you in life and he
would be so pleased and honored to have
an award that really brings together two
things that he loved he loved public
service he loved history and he loved
the Arts in fact when he wasn't in
Washington working on the massive amount
of legislation and this would struggle
for social justice and equality and all
the things we know about his political
leg
see he loved being with artists he
thought that artists were creative funny
great conversationalist and just and you
know what they loved his company too and
I don't think we could think of a
greater way to honor my dad than to
establish an award like this to make
history come alive and two because my
father thought that all of us had a
story to tell in our lives and and
through the arts and the creativity of
so many brilliant people here in our
country and around the world that is
what makes this so special so to
suzan-lori and to your mother Frances I
want to recognize Francis thank you so
much for coming here tonight and for
raising such an amazing daughter and
we're looking forward to seeing to
seeing all of you in the reception
immediately following our our our
program this evening and I'll just just
echo my brother and say thank you all
and my dad absolutely love the theatre
of life he loved people when we went out
campaigning he enjoyed the experience of
going to different parts of the country
to talk to different people and hear
about the drama of their life because
really his job was taking that drama and
trying to formulate it into a narrative
which would then become a piece of
legislation which would then hopefully
help people in their real lives so there
is a lot of intersection here and I'm
honored to be also at the front row seat
just like I was in his life to seeing
all that he did to see this drama award
come to fruition and I thank you all for
making that possible thank you guys
that which we are we are one equal
temper of heroic hearts strong and will
to strive to seek to find and not to
yield for all those whose cares have
been are concerned the work goes on
the cause and doors the hope still lives
and the dream shall never die
no matter who writes the history books
when people look back on this century
they will say that Edward Kennedy was
one of the ablest and most productive
most compassionate and most effective
men who served in the United States
Senate in the entire history of the
country my father loved this country and
was fascinated by the men and women who
helped to shape its history whenever he
felt the need to better understand an
issue he often looked back to how others
had solved similar problems
he loved historical documents and
biographies their perspective helped him
gain understanding not only of their
time but of our own Abe Lincoln was a
quiet and a melancholy man but when he
spoke of democracy this is what he said
he said as I would not be a slave so I
would not be a Muslim this expresses
my idea of democracy
whatever difference from this to the
extent of the dip
is no democracy
and welcome my grandmother Rose
Fitzgerald Kennedy gave tours of her
home in Hyannis Port yeah it's a very
charming little picture of Ted with his
father at the Embassy looking very
serious whoo and a wonderful round of
the president late President Roosevelt a
tradition my father followed giving
tours of his office at jaimey like
Grandma he could narrate our nation's
history from an extraordinary point of
view picture President Kennedy
don't tax that he is wearing in the
Pacific my father wanted to make history
come alive
he created the annual family history
camping trip
he packed up all of my cousins and took
us on trips to visit famous American
sites in the company of historians
a senator Kennedy has been taking his
nieces and nephews and many of his
family to historic places year after
year it's a wonderful family tradition
it ought to be a family tradition
everywhere because those trips can
change your life he took us to Plymouth
in the South Shore the homes of
nathaniel hawthorne in herman melville
in the Berkshires Paul Revere and
longfellow house the Freedom Trail the
USS Constitution the Brooklyn Bridge
Harpers Ferry manassas Mount Vernon Fort
McHenry and a church in Richmond after
senator Kennedy's most recent visit
where Patrick Henry made his famous
speech Ted nearly tackled me on the
Senate floor the next we could tell me
about it and how exciting it was to him
and end to the members of his family can
insist that every child is going to
develop a love of history or an
understanding but we sure can do
everything we can to give an opportunity
for the young people his love of
American history and his place in it is
treasured by our family but his
contributions to celebrating and
preserving our history is his lasting
gift to all Americans my brother edward
moore kennedy was the last of my mother
and father's nine children
right from the start he captured our
attention
my mother had an insatiable interest in
history literature in the arts and she
taught and quizzed each of us about what
she thought was important mother
required teddy to memorize the poem The
Midnight Ride Paul Revere she felt that
longfellows poem was a wonderful way for
her children to learn about poetry and
history at the same time listen my
children and you shall hear of the
midnight ride of Paul Revere on the 18th
of April and 75 hardly a man is now
alive who remembers that famous day and
year Teddy always said that early
exposure to our nation's history and
literature had an immeasurable impact on
his life an avid reader of biographies
he authored his own drew compass as well
as several others including a children's
book and how laws are made as told
through the eyes of his beloved dog
splash
he admired the visual arts it was an
accomplished painter who shared his work
with friends and family
music was perhaps dearest to him a gift
from our grandfather honey Fitz and our
mother I Ted if you know sing sweet
Adeline I used to play for him on this
piano
Oh
No
never maybe 0
mmm
haha
Teddy and I shared an enjoyment of
theater
especially for him musical theatre he
admired the discipline and skilled a
theatre demanded of actors directors
and writers
he was intrigued by the theaters
creation of worlds based on the human
imagination either for the purposes of
escaping was difficult in life or for
the purposes of confronting difficult
truths we love the creative community
and the feeling was mutual he was an
ardent student of American history and
of course he devoted his life to public
service for over forty years in the
United States Senate he championed the
role of the Arts and Humanities and the
promotion of our culture life as
integral to the American experience
Teddy could have done anything with his
life and so he chose to do everything
you're all the better for it
when i get to be when i get to be when i
get to be a composer all right gonna
ride me some i'm gonna ride me some
music i'm gonna write me some music
about daybreak in alabama and I'm gonna
put the purty songs in it rising out of
the ground like a swamp missed and
falling out of heaven like soft you
gonna put some tall tall trees in it and
the scent of pine needles
and the smell of red clay after rain and
long rednecks and poppy colored faces
and big brown arms and the field Daisy
ah
eyes of black and white black white
black people and I'm gonna put black
hands and white hands and brown and
yellow hands and red clay earth hands in
it touching everybody with kind fingers
touching each other natural as do in
that dawn of music in that dawn of music
when I get
to be when i get to be when i get to be
a composer and write about daybreak in
alabama
I'm deeply honored to be part of the
celebration this evening of this year's
winner of the Edward M Kennedy prize for
drama inspired by American history for
some 25 years suzan-lori parks has been
writing plays that engage american
history in ways that don't just fill in
some of the gaps in the standard
tellings of our national narrative but
that counter counter intuitively perhaps
but urgently dig more deeply into them
and pry them open more widely this is
the play right after all who once set
one of her plays to quote the stage
directions in a great hole in the middle
of nowhere an exact replica of the great
whole of history like the gravedigger in
the center of that work the America play
parks exhumes what our world wants to
forget and lays it bare for us to
contemplate and complicate the word
replica is key in that stage direction
as parks has always been interested in
the problem of representation as a
productive problem built into the
theatrical art itself and as a
incomplete experiment of American
democracy whether in a choral poem about
the middle passage that fills a darkened
stage in the arcade game of
assassinating and Abraham Lincoln look
alike in this in in the dog eat dog
contest between two scamming brothers
parks has used dazzling stage metaphors
in gorgeous lyrical language to tell
stories about individuals struggling
within the sweep of time over issues of
promises fulfilled or betrayed faiths
kept or rejected as they narrate
themselves into social being to this
astonishing body of work parks has now
added the masterpiece father comes home
from the wars parts 1 2 & 3 set in 1862
and 1863 the play begins with hero a
slave on the brink of a decision over
whether to heed his master by assisting
him as a soldier in the Confed
army each of the three parts centers on
a profound moral conundrum a choice
involving the vexing question of freedom
and obligation and freedom that is never
individual but also but that always has
social and communal consequences and the
vexing question of the agonizing
upheaval of change audacious and deeply
human both epic and intimate father
comes home is tragic in its dimension
even as it kicks open the closed moral
options of that historical form the
first third of a plan 9 part cycle that
will move up to the present day parts 1
2 & 3 already hint at the 21st century
and there sly language and enjoy
Bonnie's beautiful production in the
costuming and in the gestures like when
hero describes patrollers searching for
runaway slaves an action that can't help
but call to mind Ferguson Missouri where
we now know for a fact black bodies
remain commodities for the building of a
local economy as important father comes
home also looks back to the Western
Canon laying laying claim to it
certainly but also boldly revising it
just as the name edmund pettus has been
overturned changing from the moniker of
a Confederate Army General and Grand
Wizard of the Ku Klux Klan into the name
of a bridge forever associated with the
astonishing bravery of the Selma
marchers that President Obama just
celebrated a little over a week ago
parks revamps the old tropes turns them
around or as she once put it signifies
on the signifying her Greek chorus
places bets on the outcome of an action
and in the plays breathtaking final
section her Penelope breaks the chains
not only of slavery but of a seemingly
all powerful narrative in case I've
given the false impression at this point
that there's anything doer dusty about
parks's work let me hasten to add that
there's wit and downright hilarity that
in her plays and father comes home and
and maybe this is a feature in common
with the writing of Senator Kennedy
there's a talking dog who despite this
despite being played by a human being
does in a self-conscious and layered
turn what dogs always do in the theater
namely upstage everyone in nearly steal
the show in this case as a turn as a
Greek messenger is crucial to any Greek
tragedies but with a shaggy dog story
just one of the examples of the expert
way parks controls timing tone and
revelation and father comes home with
great respect for Senator Kennedy and
everyone involved in the granting of
this important prize I'd like to tweak
its title the title of the award a
little bit tonight to recognize what I
see as one of the essential gifts
suzan-lori parks his works bring us
namely a view of history as always in
process as she reminds us in a
quintessential theatrical way that the
past on stage always unfolds in the
present so I'd like to offer offer my
heartfelt congratulations to suzan-lori
parks not just for writing a brilliant
play that is inspired by American
history but that itself inspires us to
make our own American history we're
going to perform a song from the show
father comes home from the wars a song
is misplaced myself and has a little
story now back in the day when a slave
would run away his master might say oh
he's right off or oh she's run off the
master also might say oh he's misplaced
himself or she's misplaced herself and
so I just had to write a song about that
they'd be searching high and low they'd
be looking in the trees may be searching
all the rivers may be questioned when
the babies I'm long gone i ain't sitting
on your shelf i have this place to sell
i have misplaced myself yeah
ain't working in your field night Martin
in your show i am turning up your butter
you don't matter anymore I'm long gone i
sold him with all your well I have mr.
Oh
you've been missing me here I go
sailing far from the dell across the
deep blue sea I ain't leavin in a trail
I didn't win and broke my chain you got
everything that Lulu's I got everything
to gain I'm long gone I sitting on your
shelf I have misplaced my cell sweet
sound I had missed raise hell I have
missed raised myself yeah
you were colored man yes I'll be damned
I've seen some before they don't look at
he's one of them well I'll be damned
you're Colonel now he'll know what's it
like carrying a gun having a regiment
it's an honor so a big feeling it's hard
to put into words you can stand up
straight when you think about it that's
exactly right you think you all to beat
the jibs God willing and the whole world
will change you'll be able to have your
own farm you move up north or anything
you want you really colored I could pass
yeah get myself more money better rank
plenty like me who can they do it but
that's not me my old master he branded
each and every one of us to tell the
world you belong to him case we ran off
did you never thought about it sure
plenty boss master he branded us too
right here badan lots of other things
what kind of price you fetch these days
I got my freedom handed to me when the
master died but if i remember right i
was worth about the same as you and
freedom might be coming no come one way
or another it'll come how much you think
we're going to be worth with freedom
comes what kind of price we gonna fetch
then we won't have a price it's like
they don't that'll be the beauty of it
where's the beauty and not being worth
noting won't be able to be moved around
beaten bought or sold forced to work
make men rich while we stay poor most
soldiers their poor colored and white
boat there's more to freedom that I can
explain but believe me is like living
and glory who will I belong to you
belong to yourself so when a patroller
comes up to me when I'm walking down the
road to work up to what have you and a
patroller comes up to me and says whose
nigga are you nigga I'm gonna say I
belong to myself
today I can say I belong to the colonel
I belong to the colonel I says now
that's how come they don't beat me but
when freedom comes and they stopped me
and asked and I say I'm my own I'm on my
own and I own my own self you think
they'll leave me be I don't know seems
like the worth of a colored man once
he's made free is less than his work
when he's a slave God how come you don't
run off maybe I'm worth something so me
running off would be like stealing seems
to me you've got a right to steel
yourself maybe maybe not if you could
name yourself anything what would you be
that's a big question I don't rightly
know both of us and satisfied with the
names they gave huh and his wealth is
such a mess how's it colored going to
make his way seems like we either get
sold off by somebody else sell out our
own self and you can be bought or sold
so could I that'll end with free what if
it does somehow sometimes I get the
feeling that the heart of the thing
won't change easier quick because the
way we were bought and brought over here
in the first place and maybe even with
freedom that mark huh that mark of the
marketplace she'll always be on us so
maybe we'll always be twisting and
turning ourselves into something that'll
bring the best price and that's the way
we were born into this so is it always
gonna be like that for us slavery or not
treatable not where are we gonna get us
a better place in the marketplace you
talking like you want to burn something
down I'm just saying you say you broke I
say you double broker snapped into
without a penny to your name hoping
somebody pay more than eight hundred
dollars for you but god damn it god
willing someday we'll have a place
besides just the auction block and maybe
that starts by stealing yourself
stealing yourself making yourself like
metal on the inside maybe it gets better
from there but I don't know
God is in his heaven up above above
while we toil bravely down
no below
in the midst of this most fearful day
let us count our many blessings in the
midst of his bride wilderness let me see
a lot I know in the darkest of the
darkest night there is still the day the
colors all right God is in his heaven up
above up a bone while we toil bravely
down below
when the road is long in the eye is weak
let us hope the heart is married let us
keep on keeping on you know let us
cherish all we carry when the stick is
then and the plenty ends or it'll be as
it is always been God is in his heaven
up above a book while we toil bravely
down below God is in his heaven up above
up above Bobby Tolan brave
you
good evening and welcome at the Edward M
Kennedy prize for gamma inspired by
American history is given annually to a
new play or musical that enlist theaters
power to explore the past of the united
states to participate meaningfully
meaningfully in the great issues of our
day through the public conversation
grounded and historical understanding
this is essential to the functioning of
democracy if you thought i wrote that
you're out of your mind but you inspired
there are two components to the Edward M
Kennedy prize a bursary award of one
hundred thousand dollars and a website
created by columbia university center
for new media teaching and learning
devoted to the prize-winning play
accessible to teachers and students
interested in an in-depth exploration of
the place content subject matter and
production history the board of
governors of the prize and wants to
thank our distinguished panel of
distinguished judges some of whom were
here tonight playwrights Chris Diaz Rena
Groff stephen adly Girgis and david
henry hwang composer gabriel Kahane and
book writer playwright john Weidman
columbia university professor of english
and comparative literature James Shapiro
Columbia University William B ranford
professor of English and comparative
literature and african-american studies
for our Jasmine Griffin and columbia
university Dean of the School of the
Arts Carol Becker a national network of
20 theater professionals selected five
extraordinary players to be finalists
for the 2014 Kennedy prize they are
Brandon Jacob Jenkins for octoroon and
appropriate Marcus guard Lee for the
house that will not stand suzan-lori
parks for father comes home from the war
part wars parts one two and three and
Robert shenkin for the Great Society the
judges met on februari 12th to select
this year's prize recipient I'd like to
ask if suzan-lori parks to join Tony and
me on the stage
at first I just wanted to say a word and
thank Tony Kushner he's made this all
hat
now I'm going to read the judges
citation the jury deeply admires all
four of this year's nominated works and
was struck by the fact that each in its
own way addresses with eloquence and
insight he is yet unhealed traumas
brought on by the legacy of American
slavery from amongst this distinguished
group the jury Awards the Edward M
Kennedy Prize for drama and spared
inspired by American history to father
comes home from the wars parts 1 2 & 3
by Suzanne Lori parks the story of hero
a slave who chooses to fight on behalf
of the just a minute can you get this
thank you the Confederacy feels fresh
and alive shiny new light on the
complicated nature of freedom in its in
its unflinching treatment of homecoming
betrayal and heroism father comes home
from the wars announced itself is an
iconic work the challenges and engages
Western theatrical tradition while
providing a compelling contribution to
the urgent American conversation about
race congratulations Darren Lori
oh yes
so we're just getting suzan-lori a fake
check the real one will be arriving in
the mail and every winner of the prize
receives a print of a specially
commissioned a portrait of Ted Kennedy's
sailboat by jamie wyeth and so it's
beautiful congratulations
community I'm gonna do annalisa Solomon
move here I I wore this dress and so and
they're filming so I'm thinking you know
like that wonderful show Hamilton down
at the public history has its eyes on
you and so I would want to look good I'm
being silly but i'd like i'd like to
thank the senator edward in committee a
prize for honoring father comes home
from the wars parts 1 2 and 3 thank all
of you who made this decision and among
the generous judges i see the faces of
some of my dear friends so that makes it
very special so thank you guys for
thinking kindly of me i'm also very very
grateful to Oskar Eustis and the Public
Theater and I you know
and and your wonderful team including
Mandy Hackett wonderful Mandy I'm Duggar
applaud you don't know if you are in the
trenches call Mandy I won't give out
your number but if you're a writer in
the trenches call Mandy and Maria
guiadas for helping me birth these the
first of these three plays of this
nine-part cycle which is called in any
add nine things are in any ad which is
now I got to finish it right and any ad
and I'll but I can gush on and on and on
but really I cannot say enough I cannot
thank you Oscar enough for your genius
producing you promised we would make it
there and and we got there because of
you and your vision your kindness your
smarts you're just a joy to be around
and that day when I wanted to change the
ending when I ran it by joe bonney that
i texted you and ran to your office out
of a rehearsal to run it by Oscar
because I knew if Oscar said yeah try it
then we were on the right track so that
kind of commitment and dedication and
love it trickles down it comes it flows
down from you to your whole team at the
public theater so thank you yeah thank
you in the house tonight yes we can clap
again
no now because we all know you know
things don't you know it takes a team
things don't just happen like that just
isn't just a playwright of the composer
or whatever it takes a team and a great
leader in the house tonight is Diane
borger from a RT thank you and your
family at American Repertory Theater I
saw or someone tada there you are yay
thank you guys you guys are awesome for
your love and support of this play joe
bonney this is the first pages thank you
so Jill Bonnie of our brilliant director
I thank you just to give you guys a
history back in 2009 joe bonney and i
were having lunch and I acted out the
entire story a father comes home from
the wars in between bites of food using
the fork the knife and the spoon so
luckily we have we you know we got some
brilliant fabulous fantastic actors but
the play the first three play it would
not be so wonderful without your genius
direction and your joy and enthusiasm
and hard ass coolness hard-ass
badassness that I so so so very much
respect and appreciate also in the house
tonight are wonderful some of our
wonderful wonderful cast and crew I came
to every single rehearsal which a which
is well in my history of theatre and
I've been doing theatre for Lou 2030 is
it never happens I never come to every
single rehearsal and in every show that
I could possibly make and it is because
I just so loved being around you guys I
would just come and hang out and I sure
it was nice to hear the play but it was
so wonderful just to sit in your company
in your presence and and it's so thank
you thank you and it's just go great
just to see you guys here yay hi Julie
to PJ guys hey Tony okay and a special
thanks you've already be recognized once
mom but why not again to my dear awesome
mom mrs. Francis parks
thank you in your footsteps I follow in
your footsteps I follow and not only do
you help me become a good mom in my own
right but you help me be a better
citizen of the planet also just a shout
out to my son Durham who is at home with
the babysitter probably watching soccer
highlights on youtube so that's a good
thing but you know scholars are just
beginning to write and speak about
father comes home from the wars and I
always see my work for that for over the
years I see myself as someone who
through theatre makes history because I
have this sort of cockamamie belief that
if it happens on stage it really
happened so with my work I work to fill
the holes the abysses and create a
wholeness and father comes home is a
continuation of that work I'm so glad
you know it's so its enormous thing for
me at the root of it it's also a family
play play about family and it's a great
honor that my family play my play about
family is has been recognized by the
family of Senator Edward M Kennedy you
guys have heard this many times before
but well your father your brother's life
of service you your family is one of the
great beacons one of the guiding lights
to families like mine we have been
looking up to you guys and following you
guys for so many years and now we meet
and it's a great honor it's a really
great honor I wish senator Kennedy we're
still here with us I wish my dad who was
passed away was still here with us and I
wish everyone who we love and who is
wonderful we're still here but they go
and so you know here we are to continue
to continue on and then those we love
will be proud of us for the way we keep
on keepin on as folks in the movement
used to say I started writing father
comes home from the wars because of my
dad he was a career he was a
professor at the end of his life but for
20 years 25 years when I was growing up
he was a career army officer ROTC that
was how the poor kids in his day also
got into college and so he joined the
army through officers training school
right out of college and he was a career
army officer and a good part of my
childhood was spent watching him go to
war and come home and we were lucky
because he would go to war and come home
go to war and come home again on the day
I was born so the story goes he was out
in the field that's what they call it
when they go out into the field the
woods and do army exercises he was not
behind a plow that would have been very
poetic he was out in the field in a tank
doing army exercises or war rehearsals
and if your life is a piece of music and
I believe my life is a piece of music
his going away to war and coming home
again became the main groove of my
record and that's the main groove of
what record plays in my head father
comes home from the wars is also about
the pursuit of freedom and maybe it's
also about the pursuit of happiness
maybe those two things are connected as
you've heard it takes place in the 1860s
and features and enslaved people the
ruling class the Civil War of the
battles are fought off stage luckily for
our budget and right I thought about
that yeah I thought about that and it
also as you heard features a talking dog
a deer dog who is faithful who is full
of faith in a world where there is so
much uncertainty and all these
characters are pursuing freedom and near
the end of part three a wandering group
of runaway slaves wonder about freedom
they wonder about the very thing they're
risking their lives to obtain and they
say the place I'm going to now is
freedom but where is freedom really well
the air smells sweet well the streets be
paved with gold we'll all in freedom
ville welcomed me with open arms will
there be a bed to lay my freedom head
will there be food freedom will burst my
brains to madness maybe maybe freedom
will flood my heart to death will I say
at the end of the day god i wish i'd
stayed home well i'm glad i didn't stay
home tonight so thank you very much
so thank you all so much for coming
suzan-lori that was astonishing and
we'll hopefully see you next year and
there's reception downstairs so please
join us downstairs and thanks again